Vamos a la fiesta al margen de la
exposición habibi las revoluciones del
amor que pone de relieve los códigos
queer del mundo árabe el Instituto árabe
en París propone una velada escénica
para reunir a todos los públicos y
celebrar la tolerancia y el amor a
través del bowing
[Música]
esta noche es una elección cultural y
política
Así es el papel de una institución de
servicio público es poner de relieve las
fallas las rupturas las contradicciones
las dificultades las aspiraciones y los
sueños
nuestros cuerpos son políticos estamos
orgullosos de quienes somos Estamos
orgullosos de cómo nos vestimos
en Nueva York de los años 70 las
comunidades transexuales gay Latina y
afroamericanas buscaban nuevas formas de
resistencia contra la exclusión será una
danza urbana el Bowling cuyos
movimientos se basan en las poses
caricaturescas de las modelos de la
revista vogue por su evidente relación
con la moda los equipos de baile adoptan
los nombres de las grandes casas de lujo
por qué hablo por qué revlón bueno
revlon es una empresa de cosméticos y yo
soy la primera revlon International fui
reclutado por los estadounidenses
eligieron entrar en esta casa y me
eligieron a mí y yo también los elegí
es genial tomar posesión así
todas esas marcas
Yo diría que es un toma y dame Porque
también se nutren de la escena de los
salones de baile
en cuanto al aspecto y la creatividad se
inspiran mucho en la escena de los
salones de baile para mí es un
intercambio equivalente en la vida real
y hoy en 2023 las marcas también nos
llaman para actuaciones para
espectáculos
Así que lo tienen es una gran ocasión es
una gran familia en la vida real
Qué llevas puesto mira hoy estoy usando
asos completo en lentejuelas
me gusta brillar refleja mi personalidad
Y eso es Louis Vuitton
asociación o compra
esto es una compra y esto es un regalo
sin embargo no todos los artistas se
benefician de la generosidad de las
marcas de lujo casi todas son cosas
hechas por mí
ropa hecha por mí
que tengo un poco de todo
solo pongo cosas muy reveladoras o muy
cortas me gustan las prendas muy cortas
y con muy poca tela
Por qué
Porque asumo que en la vida cotidiana no
soy muy afeminado ni femenino y por eso
cuando puedo permitirme ser afeminado
femenino me gusta que sea muy corto muy
transparente
y siempre con barba siempre siempre
siempre
para seguir siendo
[Aplausos]
el mensaje de esta noche es simplemente
intentar que la gente sonría y se la
pase bien al tiempo que les hacemos
reflexionar sobre el hecho de que la
feminidad ya sea para las mujeres las
mujeres pasan por cosas horribles en la
vida cotidiana como los homosexuales y
las mujeres transexuales Y eso es todo
queremos mostrarles que la feminidad es
hermosa y se celebra tiene una feminidad
frustrada
lo experimenté mucho y es verdad que el
Bobby me ha ayudado a pensar que está
bien en realidad y es no tiene nada Ser
femenina porque a menudo puede estar mal
visto
O puedes llamar la atención de los
hombres
No necesariamente en el buen sentido
o se tome como algo seductor es solo mi
personalidad que aparece en este momento
es muy importante que la cultura tenga
una visión un significado una misión que
no sea solo para la expresión del
artista todo el proceso artístico tiene
que tener sentido tiene que tener algo
que represente algo que cambie un
impacto en el mundo
y el bowing empieza a hablar cada vez a
más gente para poder inyectar un poco a
nuestra pequeña escala
estas Buenas prácticas de aceptación
tolerancia y conocimiento de cómo
convivir
estrella invitada de la noche la rapera
italiana underground mixqueta nunca se
quita las gafas nunca deja su máscara
Esto se debe a que las luces son
demasiado brillantes para mis ojos
no es solo porque me siento más libre
con una máscara puesta
disqueta es un personaje con máscara
porque a veces una máscara puede revelar
más que
hay un rostro bajo la máscara de
disqueta pero sobre todo hay un instinto
hay energía pura y de igual manera me
gustaría que todo el mundo pudiera verse
reflejado en mi disqueta es político nos
aceptamos a nosotros mismos
la noche es un momento especial para
experimentar este tipo de emociones
emancipación individual libertad de amar
libertad de existir en la propia
diferencia gracias a la ropa La música y
la danza un hermoso compromiso cultural
y político
[Aplausos]